mai nishida bunker and i represent
company called valley escape this is a
relatively new company we started
developing this product about three
years ago and we're going to go live
with this product in the market January
next year so i'll show how how we use
mathematica when we develop this product
and design a product how we decided to
integrate Mathematica into this product
so alternative some of the few slides
explaining how the product works and
then while I show the parts of the
product I'll also show very integrated
Mathematica so this is about the company
what we want to do is we are in the real
estate space the real estate appraisers
are the people who eventually tell the
lenders what's the value of a house
residential appraisers they have the
final say as to what's the value of your
house without the appraiser saying this
is the value the lender will never sign
up on a loan so the appraiser plays a
very important part and the industry
today is the way the appraisers come up
with the valuation is they have a method
called sales compatible method basically
what they do is they find out what are
the closest possible sales in those area
and they do some kind of average to do
some adjustment of the values but what
we are bringing to the table to the
appraisers we are trying to change the
industry and bring more analytical tools
in the industry is by bringing more data
and more analytics and help the
appraiser come up with a real valuation
so this is our Miyamoto this is a mantra
that we want to help the appraisers to
do the proper evaluation or proper
valuation of a collateral which is a
property we will incorporate in may 2013
we have a 40-plus US patents pending we
are dealing with the evaluation risk and
the information overload for the
appraisers basically what we are saying
to the telling the appraisers you need
to look at the data willing to look at
the analytics that needs to be
transparency there needs to be
credibility and supportability this is
important for the lenders
the people who consume what the
appraiser produces they are the ones who
are going to consume this and they need
to have the report a credible report and
findings in the report are supportable
that's important for the industry and
our approach has been to provide tools
to the appraiser which are mobile have
analytics in a way to analytics and
provide audit trails the last part is
very important for the lenders and
basically it's right now or the app is
available in the App Store under that
logo it's called valuation navigator and
yesterday we've all aboard for the
technology from Wolfram and we think
think we thank Wolfram for this our buzz
are we have been talking to a lot of
people in the industry and these are
some of the course that we heard from
people from the leaders of the industry
coming down to the technology the
technology that we have built is will
elaborate the mobile cloud computing
technology the appraiser uses iPad the
technology is available on ipad which is
a which is a big leap for an appraiser
they're used to going out in the field
writing on a piece of paper coming down
to his office entering in this desktop
computer that's a big lip because now
with the app they can do the complete
report right out of the field using the
mobile technology the mobile technology
the app is supported by the cloud what
we call the valuation navigator Web API
and it's basically it's a it's the
internet connectivity which in this to
that helps the appraiser look at the
data look at the analytics right in his
iPad and we have a security around it
that's one of the important aspects that
need to be secure this is and if you
look at the cloud side of it this is our
architecture in the cloud we leverage
Microsoft Windows Azure cloud technology
on the top you'll see the API that
what's exposes the entire cloud
functionality out to the
well app using the web api those are the
exposed interfaces behind the scenes
there is the Microsoft service bus
service bus is the one that distributes
work so the web ups don't talk to the
service they talk to this sir the
service bus they drop data it's like a
queue then drop the data the request in
the queue and then we have the services
sitting behind the scene on one side we
have order and data services there's a
set of so-called cloud services in
Microsoft work terminology the set of
servers that are scalable up and down
whenever we need it based on their load
they will read the inputs from the
service bus they will do the computation
if required they will go out to our
external vendors we read data from
multiple external data vendors we get
public records we get mls data we get
plat maps we get flood maps we get cos
theta and so and so forth and on the
other side which is I think more
relevant for this talk is we have a
computational service on this side we
have data service and other thing and
order services on the other side where
the computation service where we
leverage Mathematica so on that side you
can see we have a set of virtual
machines that run our code and and those
machines have Mathematica installed on
them and that core leverages what the
mathematica services product provide so
so and we can see in between we have we
need we need to persist the data and we
use a MongoDB that's our database of
choice and if you look at the app itself
this is what the app looks like and in
the iPad appraiser will seize orders and
you can see how it's designed there's a
left hand side menu the artist you can
see you can select an order and start
walking on the order when it's the order
it means really an appraiser got an
order from a lender saying that I want
you to appraise this property and you
can see here once the appraiser picks up
a property the address of the property
is down below it there and then you can
see the first thing that the appraiser
does it looks at the separate property
we directly shown the app
the data we collected from the external
vendors the data vendors we show the
data to the Opera the UH present himself
does it have to go out and get the data
it's all integrated and it's all left on
the map here we support of course all
the map standard maps in addition to the
standard data there's something or flood
maps it's one of the deliverables that
your present does to the lender because
he the lender need to know is this
property in a flood zone but there is a
risk otherwise so that's why we provide
the flood information in this property
is not in flood zone there's something
called plat map this is when there's a
new construction going on and the
Builder has a map that's that's
certified by the city saying that this
is the plat map so sometimes the lenders
take a look at it it's all integrated
and of course we have navigation too
because its own iPad now this is where
Mathematica really the power of
Mathematica really comes in early in our
product development we really decided to
use Mathematica because we looked at
it's it's a it's functionality how its
interfaces work and we decided to
leverage Mathematica and you can see one
of the things we do is the appraiser
needs to define before he comes up and
to this property say what's a value of
this property you need to define
something or as his market what is
called neighborhood and what we do here
is you can see there is a the icon out
there that's for the subject that said
that's just subject property and around
that we pull the data from the data
process like there's something called
mls all the realtors they've dropped in
data in those systems people that data
we also get data from the counties that
we call public records we put it all
together and we show that information
there and you can see there's what we
call a heat map behind the scenes it's a
hit peb that we use mathematica we
basically compare the subject property
its characteristic visa we the all the
other data points that we got all the
information were other properties and we
compare them and say how similar or
dissimilar is it to the subject property
and we display that as high heat map and
we show the color so that the approach
which
make it simple for the appraisal
appraisers are not mathematicians they
need simpler tools so that's where the
power of Mathematica comes into picture
so basically this is one of the density
plots we show and then we just simply
display however it's similar to similar
and the appraiser can't decide based on
this what is my market because now you
can see here around the subject and
typically a present need to stay around
the subject because you can't pick up
market that's far away from the subject
but your market sometimes can be divided
into two different parts they're not
necessarily connected it may be
separated and that's allowed and this
gives the appraiser a good idea of what
his market is and now he can decide what
and now we can define what is market is
and to show you the power of Mathematica
the colors that you see here how similar
dissimilar these properties are driven
by these parameters and what we call a
heat pipe criteria so basically a
praiser says look in my area because I
am the expert in this area and I know in
this area age doesn't matter age of a
house doesn't matter what matters is how
much is the GLA it's called cross living
area how much is living square foot area
and you can see here in this case I've
made everything else 0 I've made GLA 10
and then h10 here because I want to see
what if the age was a factor and you can
see here now that a lot lot more heirs
because now that means now these houses
are more dissimilar to a subject
property because now age is a factor but
is in the earlier one that we saw age
was not a factor so you can see how we
can give visually close to the appraiser
what is market should be and I put a
little bubble there that says where we
use mathematica and then once the
appraiser says what is it looks at its
market and say okay I need to define my
market the appraiser will this is I
paired to your present villagers finger
or a stylus and define and draw
boundaries and you can see we allow the
oppressor define multiple boundaries
that's it now it's decided b1 and b2 its
boundaries and then what we do is I eyes
an appraiser will say okay I've drawn
this two boundaries
but our this similar neighborhoods are
the different neighborhoods and then we
we have tools their basic compare again
we use Mathematica we do behind the
scenes it goes out to the cloud it does
the comparison of those two markets and
speed it out here is images we can
compare I skipped some steps in between
but one of the important things for the
appraisers know is okay I've drawn this
markets but we need those what I'm doing
with this drawing of the boundaries is
I'm defining a geographical area but it
is quite possible within that
geographical area there are some
properties that are not fitting in your
model it doesn't fit in your style and
rather than the appraiser trying to find
out those himself we use mathematical
functions to say which which properties
are dissimilar with a vehicle market and
we spit it out here you can see how we
show graphically the appraiser and so
look your market the region that you
drew can be divided in two parts there's
a low-end market as a high-end market
you can decide as an appraiser oh I want
I don't want to include a high in
markets but you can see how it skews of
the the values the appraiser can't
decide okay I'm going to stay with the
low-end market because that's my market
and again we leverage Mathematica here
we one of the things that the appraiser
has to do later on is in his report to
say he has to answer question is this
property similar to the rest of the
properties is a similar or dissimilar
and we just show you visually does it
fit we use each of the characteristics
like we call GL a gross living area
number of bedrooms bathrooms number of
parking spaces those are the
characteristic we use to tell the
appraiser does it fall into your two
sigma boundaries or not or not so that's
a visual clue for the appraisal rather
than just tell the appraiser with the
fits or just give numbers we also
leverage Mathematica to do trend
analysis with visibly the data we got
says one of the are one of the questions
the appraiser has to answer is how is
the neighborhood behaving what are the
trends in the neighborhood are the
prices going up are the prices going
down
simples statistics and we use leverage
mathematic again so we will get the data
we fit if we speed with the data to
Mathematica and it spits out these
charts and it's integrated and that's
another set when it comes to the
appraiser to AB mentioned earlier the
appraised use sales compatible as the
major method to use to come out a value
we have now introduced with the app the
multiple regression because we have the
data and we have the capability to the
regression they also have listening
compatible approach sometimes they use
there is also cost approach sometimes
they use but the major won't be
introducing is the multiple regression
and this is where the power of
Mathematica comes to the picture what we
do is in the app itself you can see here
as soon as you go to the regression
module here in the app what we do is
these are the characteristics of the
property that we could use in the
regression and based on the knowledge of
the appraisal industry these are the
characteristic of the determine that are
potentially can be used some of the
characteristics we say are not available
for your regression because we don't
have data the data that we got from the
from the data vendors there is no
sufficient data so we instead of the
appraiser running a regression and then
coming out to the wrong value we right
away say you can't use this and you can
tap on and find out why it's not
available but otherwise we say these are
the five characteristics that are
available to you you could use them so
we kind of do a guided regression as you
can see here and all you have to do at
this point now the appraises as I
mentioned they are not mathematicians
you run the regression and what to do
with it there's always a question mark
so we try to make it as simple as
possible today and when you run the
regression and you get an output there
is always a process involved how do I
interpret this result so what we try to
do is we try to make it simple for the
appraiser what we do is once you've run
that that Run button we go out to
Mathematica run the regression come back
and then we we apply the knowledge that
you bring to the table and we say look
these are the potential errors in your
model if you just adopt this bottle here
these are the error
should enter place for example in this
case says the age typically in the
appraisal industry you'll find any
market in us the value of the house
decreases as more aged it becomes
whether this model came up with a
positive value that means it said your
your value of the house will increase
based on this age that means is
something wrong with the model so we
bring out those ideas the the alerts
here right away and then this is the
this is the actual output of the
regression we show the regression
characteristics year of the output the
VCH to the r square we are given the
like a little bit more readable names
rather than calling it r square we call
it models predictive power so that is a
term that the appraisers can understand
installing r square adjusted r square
because adjusted predictive power better
spread of data accuracy the model the
amount of data available and at the end
of this you can see it a little bit of
composite reliability score we call it
the idea behind this is is a it's kind
of a composite value based on this the
756 character say about it's it's it's a
little algorithm you apply to say what's
the composite value rather than look of
those look at those values individually
we say this is the composite value so
that when you are doing at iterations
you just look at that value and say is
it increasing or decreasing so just look
at one number it's it's a tool that we
provide to the appraisal but otherwise
you can see here we assure those
variables and you can see we show those
some of those things in red and green
the green ones are good ones everything
seems to be good p value is good less
than 0 point 0 5 anything that's about
25 5 percent is for the limit we use
forth for the prediction predictive
power and then at the end we have a
little bit thing there that says what's
the value by regression for that
property and we also show two more extra
things what's the best five saves and
best 10 sales this is just for the
appraisers to know if I just take the
best 10 sales of 85 what should be valid
but typically they will end up using the
regression value as a computed value as
you call it but having come to this
point you cannot adopt this model right
away
because there could be problems and as
we saw that there was some red variables
out there so the appraiser would
typically do iterations and to do it
eration there are many several methods
one of the methods of course is I see
there are some outliers I might want to
take out some outliers because they
don't fit into my model so we show this
the plot here and you can actually go
and tap on a point and look at what the
point is what are the characteristic of
it why is it out outside why's it inside
you can take a look at it we also show
cooks distance just in case somebody's
interested or you can take a look at the
entire data set and say okay I don't
like this value I can sort it and say
anything outside thirty percent of the
adjusted not adjusted predicted versus
the actual price take it out so I can
apply filters here or the third way is
we provide a trim box which at this
point is the one that there is normally
used because it's easy to use we provide
a trim box you just draw use a finger or
draw a box inside outside keep
everything inside everything that's
inside is what is use for the next
iteration and you run the iteration and
if the president wants to know why is
that in red we provide explanation out
there we also provide a residual plot if
somebody who is more advanced in
regression wants to is interested in we
provide this residual plot we also
provide will we also allow iterations so
we can now take actually take a look at
it and say no I want to go back to the
original model because I deleted some
point I would go back to the original
one and start all over again you can do
a reload every star we also allow a
present delete iterations because I
don't want to see that in my comparison
compare iteration compare your models
and at the end of it the appraiser says
okay i'm done with this I've done five
iterations this is the moral I like the
best because it gives me the right
everything seems to be good everything
is green and then they adopt the model
and one of the things they do here is
the regression use these variables and
came out with these coefficients for
this
variables and these variables are used
in the next valuation model which is the
by sales compatible one of the things
the appraisers do is they say okay which
I'll show in the next slide is I want to
compare this house to another house that
house are sold for or three hundred
thousand dollars but that house and this
house there's a difference this one has
three bedrooms then one has four
bedrooms so I'm going to adjust the
price of this house because there's one
less bedroom by using a value of the
bedroom so they do an adjustment this
one spits out what those potential
adjusted values are so there's another
side benefit of using regression and I
can run regression at the end of it I
adopted model then we move on to the
next next valuation methods so that was
the regression and where we leverage
Mathematica substantially to to to run
the regression one of the things we are
doing is one of the things we are doing
is we are bringing optimization
techniques in regression so that the
present doesn't have to go through
iteration they hit a button this is
optimized and then you get optimized the
next one is sales compile this is a
typical method their present have used
and it's also supported bears and these
are kind of standard functionality where
we show the information about
comparables they will pick up the three
best or six packs appraisers they do the
adjustments this is the screen within
two adjustments and come up with a value
there's a cost approach we support we
also use Mathematica here the photos are
integrated you can take your iPad and
take the photos we do integrated
sketching at the end of it you have used
for different valuation methods we and
then the appraiser reconcile that say
okay based on these four matters my
value of the houses also this is where
the appraiser decides for himself what
the value of the houses and then all
that information goes out to the
something called form and this is the
form that gets delivered out to the
appraisal in terms of the mathematic
integration just to come back to that
Chris straightforward we have dotnet
cloud we use a mathematica dotnet link
library that's how we reference what we
have done is we have encapsulated
Mathematica
into our own class there are two
potential styles for calling Mathematica
in yours dotnet code you can call in
line calls so call your Mathematica
engine directly in the last line you see
you call evaluate or one of the methods
we follow is put our scripts into an
external file so all the commands are
the external files with parameters and
then later on we use that we call that
external file passing the parameters let
mathematic evaluate and that's that's
the the presentation thank you for time
I know this is a slightly different
topic rather than that very very intense
technical sessions that you have